hey what is up everybody it's annamac
here for
anime uproar and there have been a ton
of rumors popping up recently about a
potential sequel
or some other form of continuation for
the demon slayer manga
the demon sir manga officially ended
back in may
of 2020 but the absolutely incredible
success
of the demon slayer anime movie and
manga sales has sparked a ton of
speculation about an inevitable sequel
i've been getting a ton of questions
about this in the comments here on the
channel
and because many news websites have been
publishing articles that
tease a possible sequel the questions
and speculations have
only been intensifying in this video i
will break down
everything we know and don't know about
a potential sequel
or continuation of any kind and i will
also be giving you my own
personal opinion about whether there
will be a sequel and what
that sequel might look like so let's get
into it if you enjoyed the demon slayer
content here on the channel
and you want us to keep it going please
leave a like and comment
it really helps a lot you might think it
doesn't matter but
every single like and comment support
this channel by telling youtube to
promote that video to more people
and of course if you're new to the
channel or maybe you just haven't
subscribed
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications if you don't know we
have a ton of demon slayer videos
on this channel already so please check
out our demon slayer playlist
links in the description now to be clear
with everyone
as of the making of this video there has
been no official confirmation
of a demon slayer sequel or continuation
there have been a lot of rumors
there were online articles speculating
about a potential sequel
and there was one new one-shot side
chapter about the flame hashira rengoku
which was published on october 4th of
2020
and yet it is my personal opinion that a
demon slayer sequel
prequel or some sort of continuation is
actually
very likely i think that eventually it
really will happen
even if it wasn't initially planned by
the author koyoharu gotoge
and let me explain why to say that demon
slayer has blown up in popularity in the
past year or two
would be a massive understatement in
terms of manga sales already in 2019
demon slayer was posting impressive
numbers
for 11 years before that one piece was
the biggest
selling manga but then in 2019
it was overtaken by demon slayer
one piece sold about 10 million and
demon slayers sold about 12 million
this is already really impressive for a
manga that hasn't been going on nearly
as long as one piece
but that was just the beginning the
first season of the demon slayer
anime was also released in 2019 and it
led to an
absolute explosion in the manga's
popularity
worldwide in just the first half of 2020
demon slayer sold an insane 45 million
two hundred ninety seven thousand six
hundred and thirty three volumes
and that is compared to just under five
million volumes for one piece
in that same time period that is
unfreaking believable and it is also a
new all-time record for a manga yearly
volume
sales and this is just for the first
half of the year
not even all of 2020 wow just
wow and if that wasn't enough the new
demon slayer movie which covers the
demon train or mugen train arc of the
manga
has also been breaking records at the
box office
believe it or not the movie's release
set the record for the best
ever opening weekend in japanese cinema
history
in spite of the fact that it was
released during
a global pandemic and again despite the
pandemic
the demon slayer movie became one of the
top 10 highest grossing films in
japanese history
within 17 days of its release and
no i don't mean top 10 highest grossing
anime films
i mean top 10 highest grossing films
period these numbers are so crazy that i
had to verify them with my brother gosen
who made the demon slayer chapter views
on this channel and who also looked into
these numbers
independently but yes it is all true
and you know what this means not only is
demon slayer incredibly popular right
now
but it is also unbelievably profitable
and it is not just profitable in like
the traditional sense
it is setting records when it comes to
profitability
and as we know whenever there is a lot
of profits to be made from a series
some form of continuation is highly
likely
whether we're talking boruto as a sequel
to naruto dragon ball super as a sequel
to dbz
or the four knights of the apocalypse as
a sequel to the seven deadly sins
whenever a series is very popular and
making a ton of money
the publisher of the manga will do their
best to make some form of continuation
happen the final chapter of the
demonstrator manga
thanked everyone for reading and it
asked fans to look forward to the
mangaka's next
work this implies that the mangaka is
definitely going to work on something
new
but that new work might not have
anything to do with demon slayer
nevertheless
the fact that the author isn't planning
to retire or anything like that
is definitely good news that said it is
entirely possible that gotoge
just doesn't want to continue the story
of demon slayer any longer
and even if that was her initial
intention to just leave the story behind
and move on
you better believe that the manga's
publisher shueisha
is going to offer her a lot of money to
make some form of continuation
and i mean a lot of money millions upon
millions of dollars
because that is just how profitable this
series has become
these offers might change the author's
mind or
they might not and even if she herself
really wants to be done with the series
the publisher will still offer her
millions upon millions of dollars
just for the right to continue the story
without her so essentially
as was initially the case with boruto
and the dragon ball super manga
the publisher will offer to pay another
mangaka to make a continuation instead
of gotoge
so in theory the original mangakao demon
slayer could make an incredible amount
of money
without even having to work on the
series any longer she could just move on
and work on some other series
and still profit off of someone else
working on the demon slayer sequel
now of course it is possible that the
mangaka might straight up say
no to both options with most people
if you offer them massive bags full of
money
they will eventually say yes but there
are people out there who might refuse
gotoge might just say hey i've made
enough money from demon slayer
i don't need anymore the publisher would
keep pushing though
they do not want to lose a profitable
series like this one
so soon but ultimately they may fail in
convincing the mangaka
still given the absolutely
record-breaking amount of profit the
demon slayer is generating
i am convinced that some type of
continuation is coming
it might be a sequel or a prequel or a
different story
in that same demon slayer world but i
think it's very likely
although i could be wrong so only time
will tell
whatever happens though i find the
prospect of some type of continuation
intriguing so for the rest of this video
i will talk about how the story itself
has left a ton of room for some form of
sequel
and i will explore some possibilities
for how the story might come back
if it indeed does from this point on the
video will contain
demon slayer manga spoilers so if you
are not caught up to the manga
this would be the time to click away all
you need to know is that demon slayer
is unbelievably popular and profitable
and because of that i am personally
confident that some type of sequel
is coming although nothing is confirmed
yet
okay now for all of us manga readers
here's how
i think the story could continue one
obvious way to continue the story would
be just
to make a prequel that doesn't affect
the ending of the original manga
since muzon has been alive for over 1
thousand years
there are plenty of potential storylines
that could have taken place
in the past the obvious choice for the
prequel would be to cover the story of
yorichi the original breath of the sun
user we know that he had a legendary
encounter with muzon
of which we saw a bit in the original
series and we know that yurichi was also
directly connected to tanjiro's ancestor
sumiyoshi with this type of prequel
sumiyoshi
yorichi kokushibo tamayo and muzon could
all be major characters
in the story and of course awesome new
characters could be introduced as well
i would definitely be down for that type
of prequel
but the continuation that we get may not
be a prequel at all
it could also be a sequel that takes
place after the events of the original
manga
it might be a sequel that takes place
between the death of muzon and the time
skip in the final
chapter or it might be a sequel that
takes place
after the time skip so a new generation
of demon slayers
battling demons in modern day japan we
know that some demons did survive the
death of muzon and they continue to live
in japan all the way up to the modern
times yushiro
is the prime example of that despite the
fact that both muzon
and tamayor are dead yushiro is still
alive and well
as a demon and if yusudo is alive then
it is entirely possible that other
demons are still alive in japan as well
and those other demons could become
potential sequel villains
not to mention that during his long life
muzon might have sold his demon seed
in other countries as well so it is
possible that even after the fall of
muzon
major demon threats are still lurking in
other lands
beyond japan which would open things up
for a sequel of international
proportions
and there are other factors pointing to
the possibility of a modern day sequel
first of all it is strongly implied that
while some of the new characters we met
in the final chapter
are descendants of the original
characters others
are the direct reincarnations of our
fallen heroes so a modern day sequel
would technically allow us to root for
some of our favorite characters
once again although to be fair these
characters may now have somewhat
different
personalities the cultural historical
and social context of their upbringing
was completely different
so of course they will be somewhat
different people even though on the
inside they are still the same essence
if there is a sequel this modern day
japan scenario
featuring the descendants and
reincarnations of the original
characters
is the most likely option and in fact
the final chapter of the series did
include some small but important details
that leave the door open for a modern
day sequel
first it was very interesting to see
that the modern day characters
mostly seem to think that the exploits
of the original demon slayers were just
fictional adventures when zenitsu's
descendant
reads zenitsu's old journal about the
demon slayers his sister says that it's
all
fictional and most people in the modern
world
seem to agree this means that the public
has let their guard
down when it comes to the demons and so
if the remaining demons are smart and
careful
they could still be operating in modern
society
without anyone having realized it this
means that a new demon slayer core
may be formed once the modern day
characters realize that there are demons
among them
demons who have been largely free to do
whatever they want
for about 100 years and another
important clue that the final chapter
provided
was that little part about inosuke's
descendant being a botanist
who was researching the blue spider lily
the research ultimately failed because
the blue spider lilies withered away
but the fact that people are researching
the blue spider lily in the first place
is a big deal a medicine that included
the blue spider lily
was what turned muzon into a demon in
the first
place so if modern day humans are doing
experiments
with this mythical plant it is entirely
possible that these experiments could
accidentally
create another demon another muzon-esque
arch villain in the modern world so even
if we assumed that yushiro really is the
last remaining demon
in the modern world at this time the
blue spider lily research
could end up creating another demon
villain at some point
in the future and just in time for a
modern day
demon slayer's sequel i believe that in
terms of continuing the demon slayer
story
the most likely scenarios are a prequel
featuring yorichi and tsumioshi
and a modern day sequel featuring the
descendants and reincarnations of the
original demon slayer characters
these modern characters will definitely
be somewhat different from the originals
in terms of personality
and there are even large age
discrepancies between them some
are already adults while others are
literal babies like muichiro and
yuichiro
and the rest are somewhere in between
still i think that most demonstrator
fans would rather have a sequel with new
characters who remind them of their
original counterparts than having no
sequel at all
but let me know what you guys think is
the demon slayer story going to continue
in some way now the demon slayer has
become so profitable
and if so what will that continuation
look like
will it be a prequel a sequel or some
other
unrelated story that just happens to
take place in the same world
definitely share your opinions and all
your feels down in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
us to keep it going with that
demonstrator content
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help and if you're new to
anime out pro
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on
all notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all if you don't do that you're still
going to miss a ton of our videos even
if you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter
and instagram at animeopror
i want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar
patrons for making videos like this one
possible a special thank you to alpha
sigma
a disciple of lord twigo himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons
including ingrata the world acquired
respect
liam thompson pate heffa ruthean yx
emperor otaku thomas jones spidey life
canal
baked buddhist tungsten tarkis and denki
kaminari
and finally thanks to our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh
steelers angel cruz anatoly kazatsky
cricket xp
joe stanton rathune de oro very gucci
jessica calefon
alicia octor hinokami and water bonnie
parks the red-haired raven florian joy
and garcia mcshamus
jack watches anime amanda c deadly saint
high school dxd 73 matthew cruz and
anthony schreiber if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value for you consider supporting
us on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you